boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are on site in Los Angeles in California
we are gonna be talking about all things
Buddhism all things digitising artifacts
and we have Jeff Wallman joining us on
the show hello hello how are you thank
you so much for coming on that's pretty
funny I got that super excited for this
Jeff's background is perfect for this
conversation he is 17 years as the
executive director emeritus now of the
Buddhist digital Resource Center which
is a nonprofit organization dedicated to
seek out preserve organize and
disseminate Buddhist literature using
digital technology previously previous
10 years were in the information
sciences digital archiving digital
library operations software development
organizational management strategic
planning he did philosophy and meki from
Boston University he's a 22 year
practitioner of Tibetan Buddhism with
several Eastern Lamas whoa okay so we
like to take a big history perspective
on things when we jump into conversation
and this is a very unique aspect to what
has happened we we find ourselves now
over a period of evolution as stewards
of earth and we've had this foundation
of collective learning that we've built
on top of yet we've lost so many of the
artifacts along the way and to now be
able to digitally log these artifacts
especially when it's something as sacred
as the practices of Buddhism and the
wisdoms that come from that is so
crucial so tell us about your thoughts
on now we have the technology now we're
digitizing these artifacts tell us about
that synthesis of where we're at at this
moment in history yeah I think the the
key saying is that that the the physical
culture is preserved digitally so that
the oral culture the living culture can
improvise continue to recreate itself
regenerate itself so when you take the
physical substrate out the found a
the physical cultural foundation out the
living culture really kind of can spend
so in the in the Tibetan case it's
extremely interesting that over a
thousand years the Tibetans really
carefully documented so much of their
experiences so much of their philosophy
and their view and the traditions
specifically around spiritual awakening
and around consciousness around
meditation around transformation and you
know the physical form that they encoded
it in there was a premium for the real
estate right these little block prints
so they had to carve things very
carefully so really the words are
encoded so essentially this awareness
and this view is encoded on the page and
you really need a key to unlock it so I
think that work is gonna unlock it that
work is gonna take a couple hundred
years given the scope of what the
Tibetans were all about for a thousand
years we call it the long winter effect
right when you have nothing but a long
winter you know you can tend to get a
lot done internally yeah yeah whoa so
now this is thousands of years of
spiritual awakening and consciousness
study that has again this long winter
period where they can really spend time
doing some inward reflection on these on
these topics and then write down these
wisdoms and it was etched into wood well
in in cases where the edge to
manuscripts first and then manuscripts
but written down I think the key is it's
written down the Tibetan paper was
hardwood paper so it's super robust the
surviving manuscripts today are really
solid actually much more so than the
modern paper so they wrote things down
in manuscript form and then when there
was an interest in gathering and in
publishing that information they would
carve that into wood so the whole
prospect of carving into wood
you know is very intensive so that's
where there was a lot encoded like to
shorten words and so forth and so it's
it's really interesting you really do
need a key to unlock it you know you
need a key to unpack you know really
what the meaning of what is being said
would you say that is then partially due
to a limitation in being able to etch
into that size of manuscript and also
then it becomes like kind of like a
compression algorithm of the wisdom
totally and that totally is part of the
physical culture that meaning that the
role of the physical culture is like an
efficiency you know to try to pack as
many words as you can into into the page
yeah yeah and then teach us about this
you say you say physical and then what
was the other one well the living
cultural living yeah a practiced actual
practice well they actually in the oral
traditions the explanations the the you
know the way I look at it is that
culture is living so can you preserve
something that's living you know you can
protect its conditions for life
you can protect and facilitate
conditions so that it can thrive but you
can't really preserve life in a way I
view cultural very much as the same
thing that it's it's a living entity in
a way it's a living group experience and
and and the so when we're preserving the
physical form which is like the you know
in in the cultural studies they call a
tangible culture and intangible culture
that that's the difference so you need
to preserve the tangible as the
foundation as the bedrock so that the
intangible the lived experience of the
culture can kind of move can have some
connection back to the past right that's
the key thing I is is connecting back in
to our our ancestors yeah yeah there's
we talk about this so much but the
hundred billion humans that have built
all of the foundation of civilization
that we have it's so important to be
able to go back and immerse ourselves in
the hardships and the their lives and
really get behind their eyes and so take
us back the are we talking about two
thousand years
well the Tibetan Buddhism which comes
from India you know started in the
seventh or eighth century yeah so the
written record is like from 900 or a
thousand AD so you know it's yeah it's a
sighs it's about a thousand years total
written wreck for the written record
then but the the enlightenment of Buddha
is like twenty five hundred then it was
over that period of fifteen hundred
years it was just orally disseminating
mostly but then there was also a lot
written but in different traditions not
a Tibetan tradition the Tibetan
tradition was much later it was the
Yogi's and the Siddhas and the Citiz the
Himalaya into the Tibetan regions much
much later the earlier kind of spreading
of Buddhism yeah they wrote down all
kinds of of things in different
languages in Pali and Sanskrit and went
to Sri Lanka actually to China Southeast
Asia so there was a big spreading but
they like the the stuff that we worked
on and at the Buddhist digital Resource
Center with Tibetan initially is in
Tibetan language which was a little
later mm-hmm
and we'll get to this but you are now
entering into this is like you know
fifteen million pages of text and a
million per day as being at million per
year as being added across different
languages as well which in Southeast
Asian countries so we're really excited
to and we'll also be talking a bit about
the tech like the metadata and all this
exciting stuff this history this
foundation is actually really important
because it like we like you said it's
really hard to cap
the current contemporary archeology of
what's going on these artifacts between
us well we have all the digital data
that we're leaving behind but they're in
data silos and and we'll talk about that
too but to be able to go back and find
artifacts that have not been digitally
organized and able to be you know
searched and able to be replicated
digitally an unlimited amount of times
is super critical so I want you to to
teach us about about that mm-hmm
well there's two there's two parts of it
really is the essentially data and
metadata right so the capturing the the
physical form of the culture like
whether it's a book or a piece of art
capturing that digitally so taking
essentially a photograph but then you
have to describe it and you can describe
it along many axes right you can
describe it along its kind of
biographical geographical social
political axes and so this idea of
metadata becomes really important
because that kind of situates the object
or the form that you're you've preserved
in the right context so without that
metadata you essentially have millions
of pictures and you don't know what they
are or what they're for even with like
advanced machine learning that can read
the content of those images you really
still need a human to evaluate what it
is and to you know ascribe some
categories and basically describe it in
a way that honors its context that that
situate sit right in the culture then
you know and now as well and that's
really what Gene Smith was all about is
really doing that work he was an
unbelievable polymath of the literature
and of the traditions and so he really
encouraged us to
build a good system that really helped
this ongoing effort you know so that
after he was gone which I think he was
prescient about that we could continue
that work you know for generations
essentially it's like sophisticated
tagging right so you yes you need to be
able to do it fast enough right because
you have this huge corpus totally you
can't get too involved in it yeah but at
the same time you need to assign the
right information to it so yeah so that
that metadata is really really really
important because that allows them like
searching an organization of the digital
information to be done and I think the
more and more digital information we
have the more and more that kind of
metadata context is really really
important yeah it's so interesting how
you have this you like you said this
corpus of that you need to the you need
a photograph and then you need to add
the metadata tags and you need to break
it down and it's good they Jean Smith
and you had this had this push with a
big team that how many how big was the
team well at the beginning it was just a
few people so it's and then you know the
large team was like 10 so it's no small
team so yeah but no testing it to what
you can do with a small number of people
right yeah yeah so right and so you had
to you had to move with like you said
the corpus was big so yet to move with a
certain amount of speed you couldn't get
too involved in every single one of the
of the images so now um you know what
walk us walk us through this process of
you have the how do you actually get the
metadata tags cuz how do you know about
the geographic and all the other tags
that you mentioned well know about well
the Tibet and the Tibetan books there's
often at the end there's these caliphs
on titles which are descriptions of
who commissioned that work and when and
where and you know it's very kind of
rich information so in the Tibetan books
or there are often clues in some in many
cases like descriptions of what the
context of that work is or was so in
that case is simply reading right but
again it's it's it's at fifteen million
pages you know it's time intensive so
you need to know exactly how to do that
and and a lot of that has to do with
being skilled at what the structure of
the work is right so so and and then
some of it is just simple library
science like this is the title the
author in the subject and you know
straight metadata what is the the form
the support the script what language is
it in you know those those kind of
really basic things yeah it's pretty
straightforward but that information
really aggregates really well if you do
that well so the metadata structure
having some flexibility around that so
that you can describe what's in front of
you is really important and that really
aggregates well that builds up and you
essentially key all that into a database
and then provide search and yes
everything on top of that yeah that's
because then you can actually dive deep
into you have this you have this big
data repository and you I'm able to cue
a search that then can then extract that
data based on the metadata on the tags
that you've set with it which is so
interesting and then it was also quite
crazy to see that out of the these and
this what is it a hundred plus thousand
books of of Tibetan Buddhist history and
that when you handed over to other alums
around on the east turn hemisphere when
really
Jeanne and I think you know we ask what
years yeah we give them hard drives
sorry yeah and I'm a hard drive a USB
stick with the hundred thousand plus
books with millions of pages on such a
small searchable that was a that's a
profound moment for for our ability to
really expand the library to more and
more people that was really totally yeah
and that's one of the one of the wonders
and you know enormous benefits of
technology because that that's just
obviously now possible if it's not
digital if it's analog you know you
can't stuff as much analog information
into that size space so you know that
that actually helps the kind of cultural
preservation part because then what had
happened what happens now to this day is
a lot of the work that we did over the
past 20 years now is on desk can travel
very easily and what we've seen was now
there's a kind of a revitalization of
the literary culture so scans were taken
and then new wood blocks were created
from the scans and traditional texts
were printed from the new wood blocks so
that's that's not a result we ever
thought would happen where it would
actually spur a revitalization of the
print the material culture the print
culture itself you thought oh well
people will just you know print it out
with printers or whatever but now it
actually went full circle back into wood
blocks and then so that was a
fascinating and really powerful impact
result yeah now I will get a little more
into the nuance of the tech I want to
hear about a lot of the you know the
origin story for you guys so initially
after your undergraduate you decided to
explore some Nepal and India yeah yeah
and then
that kind of led you in to teach us
about this oh yeah I mean it's just the
ultimate expression of naivete right I
mean I had no idea actually it was his
22 years old right after college and I
had studied a lot of like Indian
philosophy Chinese philosophy in school
at BU had some great teachers in the
philosophy department and I painted a
couple houses that summer and went
initially with a friend to India and I
remember actually arriving at the
airport and the customs agent in India
looked at my passport and looked at me
and then shook his head like basically
like you have no idea what you're
getting yourself into so I don't know
what I was presenting but it was sure it
was naivete it was you know yeah with
long blonde hair and like sparkly like I
have no idea what I'm doing here and I
just was I was called you know I felt
really connected to India always have
still do it's really a beautiful country
you know friends there but also the
Himalaya like I was traveling with a
friend at that time and he you know good
buddy of mine and he after a few months
he was like I can't do this anymore I'm
going to Scotland to drink tea and a
veranda and I sensed a joke to this day
that we still joke about as like okay
and you can do that but I'm gonna stay
here and I went to Nepal
and I just stayed there for a couple of
months and I remember actually my first
encounter with a Tibetan lama was up in
the Khumbu area which is the area near
Everest and we went up and we walked it
was like three-week swap because there
was you know the transport there was in
1988 right so it was a different world
there then than it is now a three-week
walk yeah I mean but a lot of people do
that but yeah it was in good shape and
it was fun and I didn't know what I was
doing you know you know just walking
along these paths and you had this idea
like wanna go see Everest in the whole
region and we got to this
region the Khumbu and there's a very
famous monastery there and they had this
festival where they basically allow they
bring local villagers and visitors into
the monastery and you make offerings and
they do some ceremonies and the people I
was with were like why do you want to do
that I was like why wouldn't you want to
do it right so again those things so
where is that coming from you know just
have no idea as the karma I guess and
then I remember going to this monastery
or eásá T curiosity yesterday and also
the design you like you had some sort of
an inclination that was you were being
drawn out to something that was more
ancient than you were like we you know
and you wanted to tie yourself into into
that right that that's so beautiful I'm
glad this is the I hope that that can
enter into the children being born today
as well as go and immerse yourselves in
the ancient when you visit different
places around the world and go look in
those ancient areas not just the new
modern areas oh yeah no I totally tell
my son today you know the sign of a good
summer is when you get you know scars
and and and wounds you know it's like a
physical exploration absolutely so I but
I remember this moment and we were
walking through this ceremony it was
just really a procession and the main
lama
was doing blessings right to to the
villagers and I just kind of jumped in
this line and I remember getting up to
this lama and I looked at him and he
just looked at me and there was a
feeling of love that I had never
experienced before it was like this
really deep love and I was just like my
whole body just melted and I he just
smiled at me and it was amazing and I
didn't actually touch Tibetan Buddhism
for 10 years after that and not because
I was avoiding it just because I didn't
even know what that experience was
except I knew that it was profound
and later on I see that and starting to
get involved in meditation and so forth
that that that culture of compassion and
love is cultivated and and very needed
obviously you know I don't know what
that lama saw as I was walking through
but whatever he saw he met you know I
always look at the other side he met me
and I met him and we met together in
that space and it was really powerful
can you tell us more about that feeling
of profound love that you felt what was
that feeling like and how did that
energy sort of keep going with that that
was so yeah it's well it's it's warm and
there's no boundaries right there's no
conscious ideas it just melt it just
flows this flow and it's right from the
heart you know it's not from your
thoughts you know or your your brain
body from your heart and it just really
it was really clear you know and I felt
like I was remembering something you
know I was remembering something in
myself that was beyond me but that I was
still connected to and a part of and you
know my current teacher who I see less
now he's in India I saw the same feeling
when I go see him it's kind of like no
matter what my state of mind is you know
there's just melting of those concepts
and that struggle and all of that just
it's gone yes I guess the question is
why does it come again but I definitely
know it goes away too so
it's good it's good information that
that struggle goes away it's not part of
our nature actually it comes up but it
goes away and that was one of the things
that really struck me about the
tradition is that that idea of Buddha
nature that we're awake were alive were
awakened naturally that's our natural
state that's our first date yeah okay
there's there's two places quicken that
I want to go you you talk about this
compassion talk about this love this
heart centric approach to looking at
someone else in the eyes and what that
does and leaving that positive wake
everywhere you go that positive or
everywhere you go that that is so
beautiful and to see that in more
children and adults around the world is
exactly what we need to get to that
unity so that we can best prosper moving
forward and practices like this are a
really really great way to get there so
I want you to pick up the story so after
that experience with the Lama you said
it took you the ten years so yet pick up
the story well yeah then I did the usual
trajectory I left India I went back I
had my midlife crisis at age 24 like
what am I gonna do with my life I did
the usual thing you know I started
thinking about my career and
relationships and I moved to California
for a few years then I decided to do
graduate school I went to graduate
school in math and mechanical
engineering for some reason again
curiosity like I think I can do this and
then I work for a few years as an
engineer and then I started feeling that
need again of like okay what am i doing
how can I improve my experience how can
I improve my happiness you know how can
i something's missing right
so it started to call again that kind of
curiosity and that longing and then
while I was working in these engineering
companies I started meditation practice
for meditation practice and I met
several Lamas and then got involved in
meditation community in Boston and then
from there you know started retreats and
then saw you know that there's a whole
formality and path and tradition and
kings in the view and practice and then
it got more and more complicated and
more and more incredible that there was
so much diversity of practice for each
kind of person and I started to get
really inspired like wow this is really
an incredible tradition you know really
an awesome tradition and its diversity
and its care it's experiential and it's
experiential grounded in that yeah yeah
so yeah so yeah so that was that was
that takes us right into like 2002 and
when I 2001 I wasn't getting enough time
off of my corporate job so I decided to
quit my job and I went on a bunch of
meditation retreats because I wasn't
getting enough time off right which i
think is something the corporate world
definitely needs to take into
consideration of letting people deepen
their experience so that they can be
more creative and production yeah
productive because after that Ricci is
like yeah the fire was lit late yeah
totally and then I through a friend who
I still keep in touch with introduced me
to Jean - Jean Smith and I met him and
instantaneously yeah he was just like
well I'd like you two to come work and
help me with the technology so and then
it took off yeah okay I want to take us
to this point that you made about this
this diversity of practices of getting
to awakening yeah there's a lot of
diverse practices yeah and after having
done the amount of diverse practice has
been a retreats talked to so many people
what what what can you say is it do
people just go in and test at different
retreats the different diverse
strategies and then figure out what
works best for them yeah and I think
that's that's a really important process
I think people need to have in general
just more patience in their own process
around that and I think that the way
that you evaluate the teacher the way
that you connect in with a teacher is
very individual very personal and I I
think it's really important to honor how
you can hear them whether or not you can
hear what they're saying because I've
sat in an audience with many very good
teachers they're incredibly learned but
it's like right over my heads like I
just don't connect with it somehow and I
think that process of honoring your own
that connection that you feel in
yourself when you're in the presence in
that kind of presence is really
important you know because that that
spark that initial connection is really
the ground and and so the diversity I'm
not talking about necessarily is not
necessarily with all these different
teachers and traditions which of course
now today in our age we have we're
incredibly fortunate to be exposed to so
much even with social media to be
exposed with this unbelievable amount of
diversity of information you know it's a
it's an unbelievable on some level right
the abundance of it there's that kind of
diversity but just even in one vertical
the diversity is incredible in the in
the Tibetan tradition because there's so
many different practices within each
tradition you know that really kind of
get at this the diversity of
enlightenment the diversity of waking up
that there's so many different styles so
many different approaches there's so
many different you know from the
Buddhist point of view there's so many
different defilements to purify you know
so there is a real there's a real care
taken around constructing practices to
address that variety and I think that's
where the diversity comes from that
wasn't really good so the you know it's
so important for us to look at ourselves
objectively in the mirror and realize
the defilements that we want to
eradicate from our lives and go through
these wisdom practices to do so and also
you mentioned this really important that
sometimes when you listen to different
teachers or mentors it sometimes
information goes over your head but with
other teachers it really sinks right in
right so it's up to us to find those
pair exactly for us and yeah interesting
yeah that was a good one okay so now I
want to I want to talk about this so in
2002 you and gene end up going okay
we're gonna figure out how to add a
properly digitized this and you speak
about this as well it's really important
to understand scale is a big deal here
if you're only doing a thousand pages
that's one thing when you're doing
millions of pages it becomes a whole
different animal zactly yes sir tell us
about that yeah I mean the scale just
influenced this project from the very
beginning at the one of the first things
I did was ask gene you know how many
pages are there you know so he had this
whole 7.2 million so I was like okay
that's a lot so like after a few years I
was like we were at 9 million I was like
what happened to the point - yeah it was
just an estimate you know I think he
like purposely underestimated the scope
just for encouragement purposes right
when he knew it was like way bigger
but that really informed everything at
the beginning how right down to how we
structure the directories on these disks
you know because it hit the the other
really overriding interest was the
preservation the long-term preservation
and and making this this corpus of data
this corpus of material portable be able
to share on disk you know eventually
print it out maybe you know put in a
concrete bunker somewhere on paper but
definitely the the interest of not just
building like a archive online where
people would go but also to make sure
that the actual data is distributed
throughout the planet yeah I mean he
thought about that right from the very
beginning so that that influenced the
architecture the portability and then
the size and the size fundamentally it's
like almost like a workflow issue right
like you you just you you perfection
can't be the enemy of the good right so
you have to do a good enough job to make
sure that that what you're archiving is
defined well enough situated well enough
in the context in which it was created
but at the same time you know given that
there's so much you need to kind of keep
that moving we at at one point last year
accounted there were about 450,000
metadata records that you know kind of
pointed into the text so and that was
you know keyed in by people so yeah by
librarians and Cambridge basically yeah
and and they're still working every day
yeah so there's still a lot of
production and and you know there was a
real vision about you know those records
as kind of nodes in a network and that
the pages were also network nodes in a
network and
how you tagged these nodes and if you
are careful and disciplined then you
have the you know right amount of
information it's not too much and not
too little then you can make a lot of
progress
so yeah the scale was really really
important from the very beginning
because we knew it was it was big and
then we speak on the scholarly
validation yeah that's really critical
always that you know vetting the text in
the sense that being able to
disambiguate versions and editions
making sure that we're not scanning the
same thing twice you know that that's a
big issue oftentimes it's not clear you
know exactly if there were duplicates
Jean always showed us that if you have
if you print a text from a wood block
like 200 years ago from the time from
200 years ago which is the first
printing to today
you keep printing there's variations in
the and prints because the blocks wear
out and so that's one problem is the the
volatility of the blocks themselves but
the other problem is that there are
these kind of what they call editorial
redactions in the blocks so as they're
printing there's recurving and stuff
with the blocks so you see actual
differences in the prints not just the
fade but you see these kind of real-time
editing taking place during the printing
process so we always had to be really
careful about what is you know what the
Edition is what the version is with the
print is and to make sure that that
information
is accurately reflected in the metadata
and that really does require scholars
and so that's that's a huge thing as
scholars contribute and just really
access to the texts and the importance
of the text and being able to describe
you know what the text is what the
boundaries of the text is and and being
able to situate things well describe
things well yes those scholarly
validation is critical yeah as you were
speaking on that I was thinking about
the craziness of trying to see what a
version was like between these hundred
year periods mm-hmm and then and then
trying to store that as well as version
control basically of saying that oh this
is the one from 1400 this is the same
page from 1800s right yeah it's like
xyla graphic subversion you know our
github you know through xyla graphs I
mean it to say that there's a ton of
variation in the blocks themselves is
kind of overstating it it's to make a
point that the blocks are not static
yeah and that's definitely because
you're doing this cultural preservation
work look at it from kind of almost like
management perspective it's so expensive
you know to preserve material like
you're at the point of preservation
you know you've flown across the world
you've traveled you know a hundred miles
in a Jeep
you have all this equipment that comes
together you need to go to this location
you need to sit down and set everything
up and people need to agree to that and
then you actually start to photograph a
text and at that moment you make a rash
decision and you say oh we have this
already you know that's like that's a
real danger so that's part of it is that
really to make sure that that you are
really serious about when you say we
have it or
and of course we joke a lot in our
organization about about we have it
already that whole comment whenever
whenever when anyone says we have it
already I always say are you sure and
that that's definitely the the genes I
need to know and withhold text this is
really important you know manuscripts
you know manuscripts are unique they're
different instances and different events
around how they were produced and so
with old culture it is really important
to make sure that you really look
carefully you also to explain this crazy
flying across the world with all the
equipment traveling in a Jeep to the
location setting that all up and then
you either you know you have to get
permission from them to do it and then
you realize maybe we have this already
maybe we don't yet well is this a
different version how so and so you're
still identifying the million that are
pages that are being added every single
year and across all these new languages
as well so you're right now Thailand has
a big focus so Thailand Cambodia
Mongolia yet Mongolia as well
Burma mmm-hmm what Nepal in law India
those yeah that's so so tell us about
how these are different ancient texts
from from different from the cultures of
Buddhist Buddhism around different kind
of Southeast Asian mmm-hmm yeah over a
couple hundred years they accumulated
these and now you're aiming to log those
with the Tibetan ones in a single
searchable mm-hmm and you would then
search them by Tibetan Buddhist or by
Thai Buddhist etc exactly yeah yeah and
just really trying to basically repeat
the model of what we did with and
continue to do Tibetan repeat that and
other calls
regions where there were were a lot of
texts or where there are a lot of text
still still present and and that part of
that again is like the scholarly
validation where the important
collections and it's really important to
work with you know really good scholars
in Thailand we set up shop at a
legendary scholars house who basically
did the same thing as Jean Smith but he
did it with Burmese and Thai manuscripts
and uses floor-to-ceiling three stories
high and we just page by page and those
are all edged in palm leaf so the
material support of the text is palm
leaf so you have to actually in order to
activate the etching you have to clean
that clean the text and you have to put
kind of oil on it and the oil activates
the script so they'll see it so that has
to be clean page by page and they're
like twenty-two thousand volt X in that
collection but it's the same process
digitized which is photograph and then
described with the metadata and that
that's going to take a while I'm retired
so other people are doing the it was
really interesting you said someone else
was there was doing Thai and Burmese
which was best really cool that other
people around the world also have this
interest in collaborating on digitizing
yeah exactly because essentially you
know you if you're interested in books
you know your life work can be about
collecting but when you amass this
collection then what you know that's
where the digital is really powerful
okay well then we can digitize that
collection and it's much easier to
browse through you know it's much easier
to kind of retrieve and find it's not
easier to read and understand that you
still have to do that work but just the
kind of a whole organization of it and
then
the durability of it after you pass away
you know you can be ensured that the the
collection the digital version of the
collection is available you know instead
of the risk of it being put inside an
institution where it's not available
anymore and so on so yeah the these
efforts of working with the scholars
that have collected large amounts of
material is is really critical and then
you've opened sourced this is actually
kind of this really crazy
these artifacts when they're in silos as
we were talking about earlier also with
technology industry and our data it
makes it more difficult for us to add
our creativity to augmenting and
evolving the this foundation of
knowledge right and so this is so
strange the private collections of of of
art civilizations artifacts right oh we
need to get to a point where we're open
sourcing and letting people scan and
enter that and digitally and build on
top of these things right yeah there's
lots of different layers to that right
there's the the sharing of the the data
itself you know the the photographs or
the images or the scans of the source
material then there's sharing the
metadata so that it can be machine
harvested that was another thing that we
did at Parc is to ensure that the
metadata structures that we created
could be harvested by machines and then
all the source code about how you build
the archive how you archive it how I
archive the material and all the code
that you write you know that is all open
source - so like the three layers you
know all has to be open for these large
projects and I think that there are a
lot of methodologies now like including
the Semantic Web which is something that
we were working on
now I continue to be interested in it
which is these are stratton firm ation
strategies about how to structure your
data so that's machine readable a
machine understandable by other machine
so if we could get to a point where it's
fine if informations in silos right
because these collections are physically
in silos it's that's okay they just the
the boundaries have to be porous mm-hmm
porous boundaries yes that's real that's
what needs to happen cuz I don't think
the silo is the problem I think it's the
boundaries at our problem the boundaries
are locked down and then you can't have
access except for one portal and that
just really undermines the kind of
interoperability of the of the
information to have the portability of
machine readable formats of Zoar mats
yeah yeah and of course this was kind of
the original intention in building the
internet itself by Tim berners-lee right
is to have an Internet of exchange not
just a publication channel or a
harvesting channel but actual exchange
so that machines could actually talk to
each other more effectively you know and
he designed a whole language and
programming language around that so yeah
maybe we could return to that that's
actually quite interesting as a part of
our future is the ability especially as
we enter like Internet of Things and
autonomous vehicle age and all of our
connected devices across all of the
facets of our lives that that that
ability for data to be able to be read
human machine readable portable formats
is is so interesting and crucial that
way the talking can actually happen more
easily I want to want to hear about the
other ties
how are you know we we kind of talked
about how you know you're doing this now
this next one million each each year
additional pages and working with
different Southey
stationed countries to add the Buddhist
text I'm curious what about Himalayan
art resources Tibetan Himalayan library
Rubin Museum of Art Treasury of live
games just about those yeah sure and
there was a lot of work in mm you know
of using technology to look at various
aspects of the culture like so the
Himalayan art resources is still very
much about looking at the art and doing
a similar process on you know really
accurately cataloging the art and making
it available kind of collecting digital
images cataloging stuff search so that
you know that's definitely an incredible
project an incredible effort the Tibetan
Himalayan library in in Virginia they're
doing a lot of work surrounding kind of
the underpinning technological
underpinning of things they had done a
lot of work that entered into the open
source space regarding Tibetan language
and ensuring that Tibetan language is
accurately represented and supported in
in the digital world and they've
continued to do a lot of work around
intangible culture dictionaries and
things like that so you know at the
beginning in the 90s and the 2000s
there's a lot of grassroots efforts to
start this work kind of on behalf of the
Tibetans and and some amazing projects
kind of emerge from that space actually
a very much a kind of nucleus around
around gene because genes actually
connected to all these projects you know
actually the reason regional reason why
we moved down to New York City was
because of the room a museum to help
establish that museum so now it's a
fully fledged organization that that has
its own mission and it's doing great
work so yeah those were kind of like the
the wild years the early years you know
yeah so things have definitely matured
technology has matured
Internet has matured there was no
Facebook or or I remember when we
started actually it was hard to email an
image yeah I remember that
yeah that but you couldn't you know an
image like the the hope machine would
show it and then it would go slow cars
like unbelievable yeah so things have
really opened up and and things have
been coming much more much more fluid
and you know like we were talking about
before I think that the main issue now
is his decentralization yeah talk about
this so this is kind of where you I want
to also say that it's so cool that
you're working with these different kind
of symbiotic orgs because they're all
doing in a way the the archaeological
logging of the preserving cultural
heritage and that is so crucial for us
moving forward and you know Rosetta
project long Mouse project we love you
guys so much this is these are the
things that are going to enable us to
look back and say thank you thank you
for petting time into logging this so we
actually have a record of it so many
things have just gone in the dust right
and it's so sad that they did because we
could so better understand where we are
from mm-hmm if we did if we didn't keep
those so so tell us about you know what
is next for you
you mentioned decentralization so India
tell us about this yeah so as we're this
definitely is informed by my experience
working with Tibetan tax there are the
holders of these traditions and the
holders of the the texts themselves
there needs to be some representation or
some voice of individuals and of
individual organizations so even as we
were doing working and still do this
work there was always a sense of like
okay well this is my text and now I'm
gonna give it to you like how does that
work so then we have licensing you know
being able to describe that relationship
and licensing and and so forth and I
think the original kind of vision of the
internet was not that it was that
actually individuals could be actors on
the internet and that actors could
relate directly with each other and I
think that the more and more
centralization that's happened which is
good in the cultural case you know it's
very good because those centralizing
efforts had an effect of preserving
large amounts of of information but I
think in the future the the network is
sufficiently distributed throughout the
planet that individual actors and
individual organizations could have
directly their own say and individual
consumers could have directly their own
say about what they're interested in so
I want to I want to work on that I want
to start to move in that direction and
all of the silos that were created
could become still are totally relevant
in that space right because they are the
storehouses of information and they're
the great contextualise errs right it's
kind of like the role of the library in
the age of the internet you know they
still have a role even though you can
get stuff everywhere like the entire
Internet it's essentially a library you
know these individual libraries are
concentrations of of knowledge and of
context yeah so I think you can have
both but I think the move to
decentralization is really needed
because information has gotten so
consolidated in these large companies
that it's affecting it's affecting
people right I mean election disruption
is just one example but just having what
you see you know heavily weighted by AI
based on a the a eyes view of you is you
know is kind of concerning you know for
me and so I like the decentralization
move because it actually allows the
individual creators to have their own
voice and have individual consumers
connect directly and that to me gets
more at the what culture is in the first
place there's definitely a big concern
with psycho metrics profiling and
artificially intelligent bought
targeting deep fakes this is a
depressing time for Portability and
Machinery Hubble data formats and open a
stronger passion for open source and
unity and I think what can eradicate a
lot of the malevolence in the world is a
lot of these practices that you are
digitizing mm-hmm because and I want to
I want to touch on this as we get to
these final questions this as we talked
about this process of inward reflection
and meditation and awakening it drives a
really deep profound sense of love and
compassion into our lives and then we
carry that around as a weight everywhere
we go
mm-hmm mmm it can it can solve this most
these most pressing challenges as we
move into this exponential technology
age yeah I think we owe it to ourselves
we owe it to the world to not lose our
humanity in the face of AI I feel like
that is what I can offer a is gonna try
to figure out what I'm all about through
its own analysis but as a human like I
can offer mac to that system how I think
and what what concerns me that's what we
have to remember you know that we're
creating these systems you know we're
creating these systems that then we have
struggle with and that struggle and that
concern is very much our responsibility
to continue to express you know and I
think that the more and more we can
ground ourselves you know in the organic
experience of meditation of
consciousness of awareness of love and
compassion and of this planet of the
earth itself and the wisdom of the
physical world you know that that that
that's what we can offer the digital you
know as the digital becomes more and
more independent of us
we can offer that and not forget that
and and I think about that all the time
when I'm in my feed you know I'm like
why is this coming into my feed you know
it's kind of interesting but on the
other hand you know it you know my
reaction to it is actually really
important to not forget ya know we took
we talked about this event it's quite
interesting to think about the next
evolution of intelligence
on earth from single-celled the multi
cell to animal to human to potentially
an artificial general intelligence and
really being able to bring some sort of
of this humanity of a heart centric even
theory to to those machines will be will
be quite interesting and challenging and
I and I look forward to that mmm-hmm
okay the couple questions on the way out
what's a core driving principle of yours
it's gotta be love and there's been so
many ups and downs and so many so many
struggles and so much obstacle one
Tibetan teacher said three it's like if
you want to do something good you're
gonna have a lot of obstacles and you
know I like that but what really has you
know pushed me through is that you know
I'm not going to think my way out of
this and and that love is is the
medicine that's such a good quote if
you're gonna do something good there's
gonna be a lot of you got to get through
those adversities so that you can bring
that good to the world and it dried that
will bring the most meaning to your life
by doing that mmm that's good stuff and
love is the medicine yeah how about if
you could rebuild civilization from
scratch how would you design it
we need an architect to answer that
question I think we would need to just
live more in harmony with with the
natural world and I think that the
abstraction that we have to overcome
that these spiritual disciplines call us
to overcome our created you know and I
think that that if we live more in
harmony with other beings and with the
natural world that I think we would have
less alienation you know it's the
abstraction and the alienation which
drives so much of our craziness so I
think that really groundedness of
earth-based wisdom is really I think we
should stick to that I think we should
go back to that I think we had a you
know it's like 5,000 years you know I
think our experiment is complete you
know so I really feel like his
earth-based wisdom and and that kind of
harmony that feeling that we get when
we're in a place of presence you know
that was so good that Earth based wisdom
and that it is quite likely that
thousands of years ago civilizations had
a stronger connection to earth based
wisdom than we do now and although we
may have scientifically probed and and
whatnot and there may still be some some
patches of this deep spiritual
connection to earth and that wisdom
around the world a lot of the children
being born today aren't being taught
that heart centric love and compassion
we're intellectualizing everything
mm-hmm so this leads us into the next
question about what would be the one
thing that you could recommend to
parents teachers and kids to get them on
that heart compassion love side of
things yeah be outside you know learn
the wisdom of fire you know look at a
fire make a fire outside you know
appreciate appreciate the abundance that
we have you know I think that gratitude
is really the most important thing
because that undercuts everything you
know if we're if we're grateful for the
abundance that this opportunity if we're
grateful for where we are right now you
know that drives a lot that drives us in
the right direction yeah those were
great gratitude so crucial and also that
going out into nature and a wise man
sees a different tree than a fool whoa
yeah yeah wise man is is is seeing the
roots as seeing the underground it's
seeing the connection to all the other
intricate nutrients in the soil at
seeing the animals Plains and seeing the
the sunlight hitting the leaves in the
process of photosynthesis and yeah it's
seeing a totally different tree than one
that's just doesn't realize the sheer
complexity of that and and I think that
same thing can be applied to
civilization a wise man sees a
civilization sees an earth mm-hmm
with that love and consciousness
differently than a fool and so to train
the faculties the children and adults we
know how to do it you know I think we
just need to remember do you need to
remember yeah yeah what exists pass our
3d reality other realities which we
can't imagine
is it does it look the same I don't know
I can't really imagine them with my 3d
kind of consciousness but
yeah often have you know dreams and
visions and stuff and and that dreams
are a lot of information is in dreams
and I think we have to kind of own you
know that as well so our dreams a part
of beyond the 3d reality I think
definitely because they're not actually
dimensional but yet they're still there
and they still have a lot of information
in them so yeah yeah dreams are so
interesting hmm
okay how about we ask you about time
what is time
well there's like I always when I was
studying a lot of math it was always
interesting that you had time as an axis
so like you would have which is the
fourth dimension right so you have this
3d dimension but then it's changing in
time so I always found that like really
compelling and that there's a math
around the rate of change you know so I
think that time is simply an expression
of the rate of change of the of
impermanence
the decay or the birth
and do you think this is a simulation
that we're in now I have no information
to deny it or to affirm it it very well
could be if this is a simulation then
then everything is a simulation right
right that's very possible how can we
how can we negate that yeah I think we
have to we have to accept that
possibility yeah but we sell
responsibility absolutely yeah yeah just
because it's a dream doesn't mean you
don't act well oh because it's because
it's a dream it almost makes it even
more important important right to level
up and do your due purpose yeah on this
in this character experience for you
exactly and wherever we move to the next
character yeah it's like the you know
what are the what is the ethical
foundation of our avatars in the digital
space and the answer is simply that it's
the same you know just because it's your
avatar doesn't mean you don't have the
avatar doesn't have ethical boundaries
it's the same the digital you have to
have the continuity of our intention
yeah like the bringing in the ethical
idea of never ever killing ever mmm yeah
this is destructive yeah an awakening to
that degree for everyone would be mmm
last question okay what's the most
beautiful thing in the world
[Applause]
our connection
and
[Music]
the wind that we feel when we're
connected
which part of our connection tell us
about that wind it's to start connection
- you know we're not alone we're we're
we're symbiotic with everything around
us yes and the interconnectedness the
interconnection that is what's the wind
and the wind is just the aliveness of
that the sparkle mm-hmm love it well
Jeff this isn't super fun that section
thank you yeah thank you so much for
coming to the show thank you this is
super good yeah really fun really fun
thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate you thank you so much
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the topics we
talked about also go and check out the
links below we'll have all the links
that we mentioned in the show check them
out learn more about what we're doing to
preserve the cultural heritage just from
around the world also everyone continue
supporting great organizations and
supporting us as well so we continue
doing cool things like coming on-site to
talk to awesome people like Jeff and go
and build the future everyone go and
manifest your destiny into the world and
go and do that heart centric passion
practice do that with yourself do that
with your family with your friends your
coworkers with people around you let's
get that roaring around the world much
love and we'll see you soon
that's it cool cool man it's an awesome
good job
Thanks those clomp that was really fun
yeah